Okay, congratulations.
You've completed the above the line, below the line module.
I trust you got a lot of value from it.
I trust you enjoyed the reflections, the exercises, going through the content.
And no doubt, you're going to be able to see how this plays out in your life over the next
weeks and months ahead.
And you can always come back to this model and remind yourself to play above the line.
When you play and stay above the line, your life is going to have so much more energy,
vitality, richness, you're going to be able to solve all problems.
You're going to be more alive and vibrant and attractive, those around you.
And ultimately, that's going to be making your life more enjoyable.
So thank you for doing the work, going through this module.
Ultimately, you're going to grow and benefit from this training.
And we'll see you in the next round.